الى تطوراته على الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه افاد مراسل الجزيره بان مسيره
اسرائيليه قصفت بلده مارون الراس في
القطاع الاوسط من جنوب لبنان فيما قصفت
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه محيط بلدات عيترون
وعلم الشعب والضير والطر حرفا وكفر شوبا
كما شنت طائرات حربيه اسرائيليه غاره على
منطقه مفتوحه بين بلده يارون ومدينه بنت
شبيل وفي الاثناء اعلن حزب الله استهداف
تجمع للجنود الاسرائيليين في ثكنه زرعيت
وايقاع افرادها بين قتيل وجريح وذكرت
القناه الثانيه عش الاسرائيليه ان مسيره
اطلقت من لبنان سقطت قرب المنطقه الحدوديه
دون وقوع
اصابات ومن ناحيه اخرى قال جيش الاحتلال
في بيان انه قصف مواقع عسكريه وبنا تحتيه
تابعه لحزب الله في قريه يارون جنوبيه
لبنان وعلن جيش الاحتلال رصد اطلاق
صاروخين مضادين للدروع من الاراضي
اللبنانيه نحو بلده شلوم المتاخمه للحدود
اللبنانيه وقال جيش الاحتلال انه استهدف
بنيه عسكريه تابعه للجيش السوري وذلك ردا
على عمليه اطلاق صاروخ نحو الاراضي
الاسرائيليه للوقوف على اخر تطورات هذه
الجبهه ينضم الينا من مرجعيون جنوبيه
لبنان مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقدي ومن
الجليل الاعلى مراسله الجزيره فاطمه
خمايسي ونبدا معك ايهاب لترصد لنا ما
اعلنه الجانب اللبناني ا من تطورات هذه
الجبهه طبعا هذه الجبهه بدات تشهد تطورات
منذ بدايه هذا العام وربما حتى قبل ذلك
بايام اذا ان الجانب الاسرائيلي بات يعتمد
بشكل كبير على الطائرات الحربيه والمسيرات
لتسديد اهداف باتجاه ما يشتبه بانها اهداف
تابعه لحزب الله لكن هذا الامر ادى الى
تدمير واصابه عدد من المنازل كما حصل في
بلده كفركلا منذ خلال الايام الثلاثه
الماضيه اذ ان الغارات استهدفت على الاقل
هذه البلده سبع مرات مما ادى الى الحاق
دمار كبير في منازل المدنيين وايضا في
البنيه التحتيه هذا الامر ينطبق كذلك على
المنطقه الواقعه بين يارون وبنت جبيل في
القطاع الاوسط اذا ان المسيرات وايضا
الطائرات الحربيه استهدفتها هذا اليوم
بالاضافه الى الايام السابقه كانت تستهدف
نفس المنطقه بالصواريخ
وبالقفا بالصواريخ الكبيره التي تطلقها
الطائرات الحربيه والتي تحدث دمارا كبيرا
هذا الامر اعيد استخدامه ايضا في القطاع
الغربي مرات عده من جانب حزب الله يقوم
باستمرار عملياته واطلاق الصواريخ الموجهه
باتجاه الاهداف الاسرائيليه وهو ما حصل
هذا اليوم باتجاه ثكنه زرعيت التي تعد مو
موقعا متقدما للجيش
الاسرائيلي قباله بلده عيتا الشعب هذه
المنطقه ايضا فيها عدد من المواقع
الاسرائيليه المهمه التي سبق واستهدف حزب
الله المدفعيه الاسرائيليه شاركت لكن هذه
المشاركه كانت خفيفه مقارنه بالاسابيع
الماضيه استهدفت اطراف بعض القرى
اللبنانيه كان اخرها في المنطقه الواصله
بين بلده كفرشوبا وبلده تشبعه في المنطقه
المعروفه باسم سدانه والتي تواجه موقع
الرادار الاسرائيلي في اعالي تلال شبعه
اللبنانيه المحتله طبعا هذا الامر يترافق
كذلك مع تحليق مكثف للطائرات الحربيه
وللمسيحيين
سقطوا في الهجمات الاسرائيليه التي
استهدفت بالطائرات بلده كفركلا وايضا بلده
حلا المحاذيه للحدود قباله ط مطلي وكريات
شمونه شكرا لك ايهاب العقده من مرجعيون من